citizens of the reject Nation it's me Tara
Erickson a long time are you close to your
personal friends oh wow he tried to go too soon I
wasn't done with the intro yet sorry today today
timing today today we're watching Elemental it's
a Disney Pixar film and I'm super stoked neither
of us have seen it nope when I go to Disney
California Adventure Pixar lion is my favorite
oh I didn't know that that's the only place I want
to buy any merch all the stuff from all the movies
that made me cry so much that I won't want to
watch again like up I can't watch that again
no no no but it's a perfect film don't forget you
leave a like you leave a comment you ring the bell
also thank you to prepper for editing this
edit this no not the edit the reaction video
he's doing it if you're not already a patron
you need to get on it because if you are you
get to watch this full entire video reaction
with me and him commenting through the entire
movie sync up with your own copy we love
you so much and we're gonna start this film
hang that what is this a new intro that Waterfall
oh this is a new Disney intro yeah yeah I saw
it on Little Mermaid oh my God I haven't watched
that film yet so that's why this is awesome it's
so pretty [Music] that is pretty so pretty we have
watched so many animated things together so many
elements already wow all over the screen
put in a coat on the fire to keep it's
interesting hey maybe fire still gets cold
whoa that's so pretty
[Music]
wowza holy junk that is a big sub
[Music] oh I believe this is yours
oh thanks what a neat way of transportation nice
oh that's lovely cloud things I love them already
elephant City your names
great and how do we spell that
how about we just go with Bernie and Cinder nice
wow oh welcome to element City little racist
how cute though is his nose it's a stamp
as well I don't know it's kind of like if
Italians came up to me I'm like can't remember
that I'm just gonna call you Mario and Luigi
my gosh they better build a
land like this at Disneyland
or I'm gonna be obsessed they better
spend 100 billion dollars they should
oh that's so awesome I love everything
about this land and it's pretty beautiful oh
except for when you ride the train and like water
spills on you constantly I wouldn't like that but
water I'm a curious I like how that hasn't been
a lot of dialogue in this first
few minutes yeah dry leaves oh
oh God that's difficult for them
fire is segregated dang foreign
[Music]
welcome my Ember to your new life is
that her name that's such a pretty
name Ember you know I heard a good
amount of people said they weren't
too jazzed by the animation but I really
like this I like it I think it's cool or
blue flame hold all our traditions and
give us strength to burn breath hahaha
[Music]
oh the fireplace nice that's a great name for a
restaurant yeah it is I would go there like all
the time everything here authentic then I've
got to try the cool nuts call nuts coming up
done good job oh all right cool someday the
shot will all be mine when you are ready
oh my God they are like the Italians in
New York City or Irish please I got it cool
get out of here
yeah man
okay yeah
oh is he getting like weaker yeah it's old
now how about you take it today for real yeah
Amber you have to be ready at this point
how can I help you all of this and the oh
the sparklers are buy one get one free that's
right great I'll just take the free one oh no
need to buy one to get one free but I just
want the free one were you stupid come on
man the customer is always right not in this
case nope oh my goodness buddy her first one
uh oh she needs to control her temper just
take breath and make connection when you
can do that then you will be ready to take over
shop is that the theme control your temper make
connection take breath make connections
okay she has a temper problem for sure
I don't know why that one got
away from me oh you are 10 times
oh that's awesome it's just some of these
customers they get me up I know God I love
the imagination for what they can do with
the items that's awesome what you just did
I actually think the Shelf items look very
real too yeah I would love some wood chips
I'm gonna put Ember out of her
misery and retire huh we are
we are more than ready for you to actually buy
something if you'd ever get up off your lazy Ash
okay girl she's sashy she's real
sashy it's good because he added
Ash in the middle exactly you got it
I got it and I will read the smoke
I'm doing I'm doing reading sorry gotta grab
some stuff are we a match true love uh I like the
way the visuals of this world make me feel like
from the characters or the world the world yeah
I don't know there's something kind of
calming about it dad catch you out here again
[Music]
I love that oh my queen sorry buddy
elements don't mix gotta go come on
you'll never leave this part of town oh that
little guy looks a little uh yeah stop motion
for she did a barbecue oh oh you
could do that with human babies
laughs Trio
some cool tracking shots in this yeah tomorrow I
sleep in and I want you to run shop for red dots
there what whoa without losing your temper
it will show me you are able to take over
you got it ashva all right girl you better keep
it in bury your feelings like the rest of us
I really love the way the colors bounce off of
each other and yeah on the animation I think
it's gorgeous to look at it so beautiful
yeah I agree it is there is a little bit
of separation between the elements and the
rest of the world which kind of throws me
off if some people were bugged by the enemy I'm
not bothered by it there just is like a little
I get what you're saying though
yeah so many stickers for sale
[Music]
Ted love these tracking shots
no did she just like blow purple
and she's gonna blow up the shop
oh god oh no this is terrible oh this is bad
oh but the use of the powers is
so cool I agree that was awesome
look at this water and environment that looks so
real yeah is that you and your dad I love dads oh
my God I was searching for a link on the
other side of the river and got sucked in
I just can't seem to find my float it's revealing
I'm afraid I'm gonna have to write you a ticket a
ticket yeah I'm a city inspector this pipe is
definitely not up to code everything's solid I
should know my dad rebuilt this place himself
well perfect I'm gonna have to write that up
too oh god oh station's like a good display oh boy
get back here sorry I gotta get these to City Hall
before the end of my shift oh buddy [Music]
she's always on the verge of turning purple
oh my goodness I feel like he could learn to
stop leaking so much and she could learn to
control our temper and maybe they
can do it balance each other yeah
you're gonna have to go to another town
though she doesn't do that but now she's gotta
it's almost like she's kind of my combination
of anger and Joy from inside out and in the
guys like sadness yeah yeah just an
extremely overwrought version of him
okay she's also like Mission
Impossible girl too oh god oh wow
I think there's some super creative
ways of using their elemental powers
ah herself and him reflected
oh my gosh she's gonna Set This World On Fire yeah
awesome
oh cool you can do it you can do it
yeah get it girl oh that is so cool
that was an awesome POV of that huh that durburger
looked good come on guys I can't get through this
she's like I had a friend oh my God
oh sorry oh my god dude
if I'm the reason it gets shut down it will
kill him why didn't you say that before you
gotta be [__] me guy she was literally
chasing you down I just sent them over to
the processing Department I can take you there
so you can plead your cake that is so frustrating
lighter temper and then like
like light all of these things
on fire I was about to send them to Mrs
cumulus then get sprayed for fungus rot
been letting him down no that's personal
her dad will be nope so nope but the main
thing is that her father can't retire
with your emotions Amber oh boy yep
so I kind of called that looks like I'm going
home early today no don't this is why the
elements don't mix I am extremely frustrated by
everything right now I know Amber's not human but
he's kind of hot [Music] it ruined Red Dot sales
did he do this oh the water guy I see you chase
um yeah you gotta be honest with your daddy and
why is Waterman pipes City shut down years ago
these elements are gonna have to
learn to work together like inside out
there is a reason we left fire land we put
everything into it but then a great what oh my God
[Music]
it was the only way to create
a better life I didn't realize
there was gonna be all this commentary on
immigration yeah too deep for me moving on
it's like immigrant Coming to America
starting your own Mom and Pop shop it's
tough and then some white boy comes
around and ruins everything for you
oh sorry you're so hot waiting to talk to
your boss so make like a stream and flow
somewhere else nice I just came by because I
left my passes for the game here last night
it's gonna take some work for me to learn to
love this guy yeah telling you guys that right
now I agree like off the bat I'm like really is
this gonna be the love oh all right all right
he's just uh it's a bit frustrating I get that's
the point where is she up there in that Sky Box
lightning
have lightning and she gets like mad so
she'll have something to teach Amber um
[Music]
I was hoping we could work something out come
on rap are your eyes the back of your head
literally called it do you mind there's
a game going on this is my life we're
talking about not just some game this is
the playoffs I don't want to hear a sob
story about the problems of some little
shop oh it'll shock matters way more than
a bunch of overpaid Cloud Puffs blowing some
ball around say cloud Puffs one more time oh
he's doing his best
so he's just like hyper-empathetic
[Music]
super empathetic and she is angry all the time
do the wave oh cool that's pretty cool
oh watch out I like this reoccurring
motif of taking common phrases and
terminologies and bringing them in yeah
whoa okay buddy there you go
power of love all right [Applause]
oh look how he can inspire all
right so he makes like a good
leader inspirational guy I'm gonna have
to take apart your dad's shop to figure
out what's going on you can't I bet this
is connected to that fluff and leak what
the villain Amber and I could track the water
from her shop to find the source of the leak
keep talking I could call in a city crew
to fix whatever we find it's a fair trade
make that deal if you can find the leak and get a
crew to fix it by then those tickets are forgiven
if not your dad's shop gets shut down I feel like
some of these other elements are so cold hard
there's not cold-heartedness amongst these yeah
I don't understand I fixed one pipe and another
oh man he he is not doing well yes
he's absolutely going to die I was
in the canals checking the doors for leaks
when I found some water that shouldn't have
been there Rusty with a hint of motor oil
motor oil has been transported and I got
sucked into a filtering system but then
I heard this explosion shot ah the roof
oh awesome oh that's so pretty
two different elements working
how can they be intimate well she can eat
those those logs while they're doing it
and then he can wear a suit a
suit I bet just hold a water
a waterproof suit and they just
say I love you at least 10 times
after my dad passed I got all what's the point now
I just go from one job to the next there's a word
in fire-ish the shock s embrace the light while it
burns because it won't always last forever that is
a great saying I like that I will remember
it to show the credits roll Garden Central
Station my dad took me there because they had a
vivisteria tree the only flower that can thrive
that's neat I was but they said our fire was too
dangerous oh couldn't go in my dad was so angry
and embarrassed so cruel so I missed
my one chance to see a bibisteria
I was
so bad sometimes when I lose my
temper I think it's just me trying
to tell me something I'm not ready to hear yeah
I like that line This Guy's slowly winning me over
yeah he's got some good Waters one-liners in there
motor oil Yep this is the source I do think he
cries a little too much I agree with you 100
that would be off-putting just like she gets
too angry though too much so like you know
there we have it
can he not survive that I mean he can he just
gets washed up with it right like he'll just
end up in a pipe again or something like he's
water he could just like blend in firetown
oh boy you better build that
Dam and you better do it quick
catch yeah oh okay what happened
to all those muscles buddy
[Music]
oh there we go so he gets
like he can get like huge
good job wow there's no water leaking
through at all you've got a little
here right there oh yeah she can't I'll
make sure there's a city crew here by
Friday see ya wait free tomorrow
to hang out with uh water guy
oh a water guy I'll be at the alkaline theater
three o'clock this whole problem is going away
I can feel it girl you better get to that theater
she better not get so mad at him that he decides
not to do the city crew on Friday and then there
I mean obviously I feel like that might happen but
uh she has to hide herself uh there he goes
again he's crying too much rain always gonna
go next there's nothing wrong with
crying love cry I cry all the time
I'm just saying this guy is literally
leaking from his eyes in a furious way
almost all day it's a little it's a little
oh they blend together that's cute [Music]
[Music]
they like her
oh shibi fan mommy and daddy aren't going
to approve of this romance that's for sure
but she just didn't get angry
because love heals all wounds
did you see that's what I'm talking about yeah
they're not once they figure it
out obviously they're gonna be I
don't know where my wife is always
so mad at me all the time [Music]
I wouldn't mind try it oh they
can't but maybe they could [Music]
oh my God it's so beautiful there I can't
even handle it a new color how'd you do that
cover yourself in minerals son get to dancing
that's cool oh my God it's like you could be
with a different woman all the time can
you change that different mineral babe
my God I love it can you paint
with all the colors of the mount
that's so pretty under the bridge
oh my god get doused in love
oh boy yeah man I mean you were curious
that there was yeah no water leaking before
oh foreign
[Music]
what are you doing here I got bad news you
knocked over three tons of cement dust half
I still have a cup still have
hard feelings because they won't
help us wait nobody pods you are city
inspector uh no I am not an inspector
huh I've come to inspect your food yep
oh it's good to me no no no no inspect
with your mouth dude you know
what would happen you mean you
know he's water he can't be doing it
I mean he's just gonna boil up inside
oh God whoa [Music] you must try these
straight from Firelands what are you doing
uh you have to have three oh my goodness oh
okay see it's really tasty if you water it
down a little water was down water us down
oh God then water no longer allowed in shop
it's okay he's terrifying yeah I think I'm failing
whoa hi ashfa should have retired years ago but he
doesn't think I'm ready what is happening to her
how do you repay a sacrifice that big it all feels
like a burden how can I say that oh my gosh she's
coming to the truth of her emotions maybe you're
right when you said my temper is me trying to tell
me something look what your fire did to the sand
glass you could do [Music] damn no GLA glass
water uh where are you going with this like a
really thick glass wall I know how to steal those
doors yeah you know you make the sand glass thick
glass some water can't get through crystallize
it yeah yeah like the attack on Titan anime
[Music] there you go all right nice look
at them empowering each other wow I've just
never been punched in the face with beauty
before you can swallow all that hot food
is it gonna hold it worked
save this for you it's special
oh my God they might be able to fear
changing you happier armor with customers
and with that food and she's been
letting love wash over her wow
oh my God Love Is in the Air unit and tired at
the truth that you're in love with water boy okay
before he dies and then he never knows the
truth yeah man who's she sniffing it out
she knows what's up sometimes you just gotta
follow your heart and go with the flow [Music]
wow Gregory for a bit oh no I just didn't know she
'd be buzzings the rest of the family oh
God how's she gonna how are you gonna do
you have a floaty for her how's this gonna
work create a glass okay thank you floaty
yeah I don't understand the rules of how they
don't set everything on fire tell you that he's
deathly afraid of sponges no I was traumatized
interesting flashbacks with this guy yeah oh oh
yeah what race is Ember supposed to be riffing off
right well any I can fix it oh there we go Amber
I think like any and all underrepresented
Races big encompasses all of
them Middle East Asia Africa
whoa that's so pretty can someone please actually
make that in real life I would buy it that wasn't
so supported by this a creative family
every building in the new city is built
from just melted glass that's foreign maybe
after dinner The Crying Game oh boy we try
not to cry oh that's a real YouTube
challenge 1979. November you were I
butterfly windshield wipers half a butterfly
when I met you
you as whole of the Water Works gonna come from
everyone and all I want now is to be near it that
is so sweet together activate the tears oh that
is so ethereal ethereal and beautiful yin and yang
it's gonna run away she can cry
oh you repaired it with glass
glass solid as a rock
consider the tickets canceled
okay I have a friend who runs the best glass
making firm in the world and I told her about
you what about the Mom and Pop Shop fireplace an
amazing opportunity for real it's a long way from
the city but it wouldn't be an incredible start my
mom was just trying to be helpful oh my God this
is not this is not good she's gonna get she's
gonna blow purple I don't think I want to run
the shop what what that's what my temper has been
trying to tell me oh Oh I thought she really did
one yeah because like as a kid I guess it was them
putting their their dreams on her this place is
cheers
be a common theme in Pixar these
days of I don't want to live in my
parents Shadow at all the writers
and animators are working through
some [__] you must light these
with your fire and I read the smoke
oh no he's gonna prove him wrong foreign
[Music]
looks like a union might look like an infinity
sign in the Smoke to me I'm too excited to sleep
in two days I retired oh oh no we're going to
throw a big party a grand reopening that way
I can tell the whole world my daughter take
over I'm not gonna lie I didn't really see
the conflict she was having about not wanting
to run the shop no it came out of left field I
guess it was Aaron she was really excited every
time we would give her the opportunity it was
never like met with like a Gruff the Box Soul
the big bow it is the highest form of respect
but my father did not return the bow so I have
this this made for you oh God the pressure it's
too much we unveiled it a great reopening come
Bernie you need your rest Amber just push her
feelings down yeah and just stick to the plan
it's so weird that like it's gonna be out of
left field for her parents too that she never even
said anything she just didn't realize about it she
never realized I get okay so it's like she just
had it hidden and just went with the flow yeah
she never okay that was her oh here we go you came
all the way here to give it to me oh no no no no
no way breaking into wait is the water the dam is
gonna break and the water goes through so maybe
she won't have to run the shop thinking too far
ahead Focus do you still want to see a vivisteria
the air should last at least 20 minutes why does
I just tell you what you can do in your life oh
this is starting to really get to my
heart right now cool get in there awesome
that's really creative that's awesome
that's really beautiful it's
like an underground city
[Music]
don't break up with him don't you do it
girl that's beautiful though wow you get
the ultimate View [Music] oh wow that's
gorgeous I think the dialogue in this
movie could be better but they rely on
this the visual storytelling components
it is I think it is firing on all
cylinders I agree a 10 out of 10.
yeah see we're running out of hair
go faster hold your breath Amber
decisions yeah [Music] no
wait wait we can't touch Maybe
yeah like why won't you even try I could vaporize
you you could distinguish me and then start small
a light touch it's just like West Side Story man
whoa gnarly oh it was okay
oh my God whoa what oh my God yes ah wow
oh that is a beautiful illustration it's like
their energy atomic particle levels
are converging this is so gorgeous
now try oh they're intertwined
see all you had to do was try
that's so sweet and it's so beautiful
what is she gonna do
just tell your father how you feel maybe
he'll agree you're just afraid you're just
chicken [__] I'm I'm fire it's what I am
and what my family is it's our way of life
I cannot throw all of that away just for
you you don't know what it's like to be
first generation man I'm first generation
and you're so messed up as a result I know
I make internet videos it's so sad I could
have been a doctor yeah it could have been
anything else honestly I am so proud
to have you take over my life's work
looks like she's committed yeah Lantern I bring
from Old Country I pass it on to you what are
you doing here you said me not understanding
is the reason we can never work this is his
run to the airport moment you're fire on
water I mean come on that's crazy right
this hmm we touched and when we did something
happen to us we changed each other's chemistry
really it's a guy who burst into your daughter's
life in a flooded old basement so you are the one
who burst a pipe what not me it was you oh dude
Your Love Speech condom boy you don't have forever
to say what you need to say I love you Amber Lumen
oh and I'm pretty sure you love me too no Wade
I don't got to credits oh boy that's not
true I did their reading I don't love you
oh God okay
trusted you you over the shop oh thank God
this damn just keeps breaking through well
there goes that it really should have taken
more preventative measures yeah I'm just gonna
say it wasn't built well in the first place
Dairy slave let me go
she'll get it
oh boy personalization yeah come on come on
come on use the sand put the glass back up
oh there we go finally no no no no no no no no
no no I'm not going anywhere uh
you're gonna you're gonna uh [Music]
oh you can put the little
light in there and run oh
that is that's all right
oh yeah nice
oh boy oh God is he gonna boil up I have to
open that up no the water will come in and
you'll be snuffed out with your evaporating I
don't know what to do oh it's okay no it's not
wait no no no you gave me something people search
for their whole lives I can't exist in a world
without you I'm sorry I didn't say it before Oh
her tears can help him live I love you Wade right
really do love it when your light bust
that is so sweet I don't want it no
what's gonna happen hey they
both died there's no way
is gone I I don't really I'm liking so disbelief
over this situation right now did they really just
do that I I'm a shop the shop was never the dream
you murdered dreams to be happy loved him dad
no there's a puddle oh thank God great thank
God he's in a puddle in the ground crying right
butterfly windshield wipers half
butterfly he cries he comes back [Music]
an old man on his deathbed remembers the summary
that's great or just say something to make
father guy cry okay you are no longer packed
banned [Music] your uh chimney needs cleaning
yes yeah come on oh see they can't
exist and everyone sees it now
interracial love
oh yeah what would their baby look like deformed
just a bowl of boiling water
hey
Amber it's time oh they going they're
leaving oh is she gonna go build glass
oh God Stark New Life your mother and I will be
here now with more time for hanky-panky [Music]
if I take one step it'll be the furthest
from the Shire I've ever been she's gonna
show some emotion the biggest Bell
honor your heritage
that was so sweet it kind of made me cry [Music]
she gave to her dad what his
dad could never give to him
yeah oh that was really that was sweet
it was really touching ending yeah yeah
I like this movie I liked it a lot it was great
it's so colorful and fun and cool it took me a
minute to warm up to it no but did you hear that
what happened to it I did a pun or a thing I did
a thing and didn't even realize I was doing oh
my God yep you're a Poe you don't even know it
yeah well that's me what did you think you loved
it or what I liked it a lot I loved parts of it
yeah I'm figuring out what is not making me I
guess I I think that the the actual progression
of the story it lands in a fantastic spot it took
me a while to like Wade which is kind of the point
because you're in Amber's perspective yep which
I appreciated I do think I guess it's there not
sure I think it would have helped at least for me
maybe we're just in the minority here I I I I I
I really couldn't tell that she wanted nothing to
do with absolutely not we are not in the minority
they gave us nothing to tell us that she would
be against it every time he said take over the
shop she would be really excited and be like
oh really like she wouldn't be like oh and I
think of alluding to that a bit earlier on would
have helped Aid some of that might have made it
more predictable than it already was but but I
still think it would have helped probably with
the conflict and the emotional Journey so that
way when you are watching certain events unfold
you are feeling some of the tension to some
of these events like her falling in love with
Wade her with the glass abilities and having
a different creative Pursuit you know like so
that way the conflict is a little bit more
apparent yeah through that first like hour
of the film totally you know because but even
when it wasn't like rooted so much in conflict
and whatever as a conflict was the you know I
have to save the shot because of this disaster
situation I have caused and we have to fix this
whole the whole literally fix the hole yeah yeah
um so I so I understand that uh but you're talking
more the internal conflict which is the thing you
really latch on to and so much of it was caught
up in like some more of that physical stuff
that I think it would have helped root it I think
that's what I'm trying to get to is it just would
have helped root it more into that um internal
emotional Conflict for that first hour but the
maybe it is just the the physical experience of
it where at times you can it everything just even
though it's the elements feel more animated than a
lot of their environment that they are inhabiting
I still was getting washed over uh yeah the
the uh The Ether the well there was such an
atmosphere about it that I did find so sweet and
a heartwarming and very cute throughout that I
just enjoyed the mood and Aura of it so much that
I even with the things that were like ah yeah this
could have been like a little better structure
and the dialogue could have been better overall
uh I I was still very much I still very much
liked it a lot I yeah yeah it's like the vibe
of the environment was really cool like it gave
off a really good vibe and I was sort of thinking
about the characters how I initially said in the
beginning I'm it's like the environment was so
realistic and their animation kind of I was like
yeah I get why maybe people aren't drawn to it
right away and then I think I realized because
they had to make them look that way because they
had to have the elements be able to so that
you could see reflection so that you could
see him eat an ember and see it go through his
body because initially I was kind of wondering
why they didn't make it look like a character and
that he was just like crying a lot and like kind
of water on the outside but looked more like
a Pixar face yeah yeah you know and like her
for fire but then you wouldn't be able to use all
the shots that they used yeah that's just seeing
the things move through him or her as fire and
water yeah yeah so I mean I can't think of the
last time we saw a Pixar story and maybe I'm
just completely blanking that was a love story
am I breaking on something there well
normally they're not just like a direct
guy and girl falling in love bit of a Romeo and
Juliet West Side Story different cultures yeah
you're right I mean except for the beginning
of up which will make you SOB until next year
um but it's not a story about people falling
right I agree I agree um yeah I mean I guess
yeah you're right I don't know I like that
traditional sense of it there's there's
something very traditional about its storytelling
yeah and yeah I mean predictability is aside like
whatever uh though by the time they get to the
end the the emotion like I was run over by Wayne
by the end of that I really like this guy when
he was dead I I was like did they just do that
I was kind of surprised yeah if they had just
let him die I would have been like really in
shock like what the hell did this movie just
do uh yeah so there that quality was good and
I do think yeah just the emotional storytelling
of it could have been better yeah fleshed out
and I the movie really shines when they're not
actually relying on dialogue then when it's not
doing yeah when it's just showing you the elements
what they're moving through how beautiful the
shots were that made me feel more than any of the
dialogue yes which is funny because like Pixar is
like really normally I mean this is still a great
film like there was a great there were some great
one-liners I don't remember the thing but it's
like just be happy that the Ember is there because
it won't always last very long it wasn't those
exact words but I did really like that one line
there was another one but to me in my head it's
always like Pixar is like this perfect writing
that knows how to write in certain emotional
moments that really can get to you uh especially
at the end that like you're sort of like oh yeah
yeah right and this I didn't get that way maybe
that was completely their intention um maybe
it was just to like throw us off the scent of
everything in the beginning meaning like yeah we
didn't we didn't realize it all kind of came out
of left field for I guess all all of us like
her not wanting to be in the shop and then
yeah I don't I don't know I but that's probably
better story writing so we didn't see it coming
but still have you seen uh turning red yes so
that was another one about different culture and
I don't want to live in my parents yes I feel
like there's another one out there that I'm not
pinpointing right now I'm sure there's a lot I
mean I feel like but I think that's been like
a common thing in animation always and it's
interesting of like artists growing up and
and then they step into animation and and then
they're using this storyline this storytelling
Motif to communicate that and there's nothing
wrong with that message and right the way it's
handled here is not like the dad is a bad person
sure is Stern and whatever yeah but he's not a bad
person I never once got the impression like this
guy's way out of line and he's abusive or some
[__] like I never thought that uh but it is I
just find it interesting how that is a reoccurring
thing that maybe we could find a different
theme to be using to be yeah to be yeah I agree
um I want to look up some recent Pixar movies
that is a very calming common thing honestly
yeah and I I just can't let this video thank you
Mom and Dad for all the sacrifice that was gonna
make me cry what's that at the end I don't know
with deep appreciation to all those who help us
burn brightly but that makes me cry and that and
I'm glad we we just saw that moment especially
I mean not just honor but as as it being one
of the main themes of Snow White with parents
who come to yeah from the different lantives
give their children an opportunity you know
um it's like a very it's a very it this movie I
think their theme meant to be more like teaching
you about different cultures and how you
can get stuck in your world when you come
to America because you're like this is safety
and we don't mix because when we do it's scary
and people are judgmental and they'll they'll
rain down on us in a way in a negative light
um and then she was exposed to a bright light with
a family who accepted her was excited to like meet
her and with Wade right but I still think you
are right in what you were saying that like it
it is show honor to the people who sacrificed
a lot to bring their family somewhere to open
up a dream for the family and to like carry it on
to so they could all have a better life which is
a sweet sentiment yeah yeah and I think with a
lot of like Latino culture Asian culture Miss
Middle East culture as well Indian culture there's
there's so many of like first people like our age
well not yours you're like 20 years older than
me right um I could just never yeah I'm 1965.
yeah 45. so there's um there's there's like I'm
first my mom's side uh I I'm on my mom's I'm first
generation uh Filipino on my Italian side I'm
not first generation there's like some I think my
great grandpa was the first generation the grandpa
the grand my grandpa was the first generation if
I'm not mistaken so um but in my circle growing up
like there was a most of my friends who were not
white uh were all first generation Latino Asian
primarily were the the races I I I'm referring to
right and you do see a lot of that pressure I I
would like my mom actually never really gave him
how much I always wanted me on top of my money in
taxes that's all everyone really cared about but
career fursuit she's actually been really um uh
well Frugal uh she she just lets you kind of do
whatever I want which has been great about her but
I see that so much in the other cultures as well
out here that that can be a thing where you really
want to honor your parents in that it's not just a
cultural thing too you can see it in all in white
people as well sure right and I'm saying that
out I really identified with that with witnessing
that I see it with some of my family members on
my cousin's side and whatever and then also with a
lot of friends who do feel that pressure to uphold
uh the Pursuits of what their parents ultimately
want them to do and to also find love within your
race yeah that's a very common thing it's like
important it's it's still very much out there
it's a real thing that happens and I think getting
that across is not a is a good thing to be like no
yeah yeah make your own choices it's nice to see
one where the parents are also being supportive as
well and so yeah I could have said that more
eloquently I know I could have I was kind of
stumbling over my no I mean I get whenever I touch
on racism I was like I get a little bit uh like if
I I don't want to say too much because I want then
I'm going to feel like I'm over explaining myself
and then I don't want to say too little because
then I feel like I didn't explain it yeah and
then I just kind of stumbled my way through it
because I got too caught up in my own head there
but I think you guys know what I'm still going
to go now I'm explaining why I explained yeah
yeah that's always a great we did a whole thing
yeah listen what I was going to say is that one
time I watched a reality show at a friend's
house the girl was like it was 90 days fiance
or something where they have to go meet like
the person but she was specifically asking she
was like my priority is that he is also Jewish
or whatever she was saying that is just such a
it is very important to a lot of families
and I'm like we would have I get it because
there's certain elements of that you're like
well I just want them to be in the same race
or in the same culture because then we understand
things better yeah but I'm like yeah but like if
you opened it up a little bit more who knows what
you could find yeah and I think what the movie's
trying to say is that if if you are one of those
people who does like I don't fault someone if if
they're like I'm Armenian I want to marry another
Armenian not at all I'm like I got you yeah don't
worry about it it's if you've what the movie's
trying to say is yeah if you happen to fall in
love yeah or like someone who's outside of that
yeah and you're only going to choose a partner
due to satisfy your parents yeah don't do that
yeah maybe maybe don't do that don't do that
follow your heart man wherever you go try to
at least try to at least try to or just like
definitely do you know I know Tara is 70 still
pursuing acting yeah auditioning left and right
hey I gotta I gotta I gotta film a commercial
on Friday okay so you know and then next week
I'm filming a feature film it sounds crazy that
you get to do these roles where like oh you're
a hospice care patient exactly and and I have to
just stand there and I feed I feed somebody soup
um for sure I thought you were being fed the
soup but I remember that incorrectly well you
just set me up as someone who's in the hospital
I just figured I thought Oh I thought yeah I'm
the old person getting getting the soup it flew
right over my head it flew and it went into the
other room and I was like we'll do a bit and then
it really it exploded well as it went into Embers
as you get older you know naturally you your
sharpness you lose your weight yeah you lose
your wit and your grit and your talent apparently
that's what Greg's been telling me ever since
so yeah um welp uh I guess you guys can let me
know in the comments if you think I'm too old
to keep following my dreams and you can let Greg
know should I try to explain the race thing again
no definitely I don't think I think in the
comments you you just it can like break notes
I think if you wait for a third time explaining it
whether you would like it or not and then when we
come back for another film he can continue
Despicable Me 3. yeah it'll be our intro
he would like to really give it a third try
because he explained it once and then explained
his explanation and now here we are still talking
about it you know because it's it's Gregory Alba
and that's what he does huh well who close this
out Tara okay listen you guys give us a like and a
comment tell us what you want us to watch next but
also tell us how did you like this movie how did
you like the animation did you also fall in love
with everything else surrounding them because this
world was so pretty and if Disneyland doesn't
build like a little world that looks a little
bit like this I might be upset because it's so
beautiful it's so fluffy that's from Despicable
Me one and I love that line so much okay um that's
all we love you so much and goodbye Korea Korea
watch that's what it says it's based I didn't
get that at all this is based on Korea Korea's
variety is saying reflected the Immigrant story
reflect the administer of Korea to New York City
I didn't get that but maybe they were just trying
to make it all in one okay reflective of what he
is his story they weren't doing Taekwondo so
I couldn't they weren't eating noodles so they
weren't eating they weren't eating Barbies Ramen
right Korean barbecue I was like I was in ramen
no it's not it's not and then I thought like
nude and then I was gonna say bok choy bok choy
Korean like in a lot in let me try to explain
the race you should really it's a racist thing
you really should have caught before
you yelled Korea okay uh who who
um what's his name who's editing this
it's prepper prepper prepper prepper can
cut this I actually control this part
of the video it's ending now foreign